oder was geht hier so agrana und heute
gibt es nur dieses video weil ich leider
kein anderes richtiges video schneiden
kann beim ein laptop moment okay ist das
sieht dies kommt aus weil man eigentlich
ein laptop ihr ist leider leer
ich habe keinen akku dabei und jacken
diesem wertpapier von meinem job bei dem
ich gerade bin deshalb kann ich nicht
leiden und so und auf dem läuft eine
premiere ich habe eigentlich alles cool
video aufgenommen ich hatte heute
nachfragen gefragt und so und eigentlich
ist dass das video das kein video kommt
dass kein video kommt weil da eben habe
ich schon mal wieder aufgenommen besser
kommt das jetzt auch so vergleichsweise
spät
das hatte ich hochgeladen und das war
irgendwie ein bisschen wahrscheinlich
habe ich lege am anfang so schräg
gehalten und deshalb hieß es dann
irgendwie aufnahmen videoformat oder
sowas unbekannt und jetzt war es
hochgeladen hat nicht verarbeiten mich
gewundert aber auf jeden fall komplett
kein video und damit war's das auch
schon ich bin dumm bei der von der nada
nicht angepackt